And the answer I was looking for is
shard the database.
You wouldn't replicate the database
because if it won't fit on one machine, it's probably not going to fit
on the next machine, and it still doesn't solve the machine we're talking about.
Get a bigger hard disk--well, that is technically true,
but if you put this,
you did not get the correct answer.
Shard the database--that's what we just talked about.
That allows you to take your data and spread it across
multiple machines, where each machine is storing just a piece of the data.
Take your data and spread it across multiple machines.
That's what sharding a database is.
Or you could store less data.
You can delete some data from your database and of course it will fit,
or you can use Mongo and it will do it for you.